Dudley North in the West Midlands labor
held until 2019 secure stama's path to
power runs straight through
constituencies like these they should go
to prison Dennis has voted for both main
parties while Sue has always gone Tory
what do they make of Labor's new and
aggressive campaigning style I don't
agree that's hard hitting I think that's
personal
and that is unfair I think they're all
they're all soft on chroma today hola he
can get away with any of these days over
here let's face it they all do it don't
they they all dish the dirt and they all
try and you know have a pop at each
other and it's futile there's no need
for it people is not stupid they'll vote
for who they want
so kissed armor today backed these ads
writing in the mail that he stood by
every word no matter how squeamish it
made some feel one thing can be said
over the last few days at least we're
starting to debate the criminal justice
system which for far too long I think
you know we have been avoiding looking
at but we need to look at hard and you
know as Kiera said you know he's
dedicated his life to ensuring that the
criminal justice system works but not
everyone is happy veteran labor MP Diane
Abbott today attacked her party's own
campaign coordinator and suggested one
ad even had racial overtones
this is a departure in style for secure
starmer and while the campaign has
gained publicity it's also ruffled
feathers with concern further up the
party hierarchy as well as on the back
benches a look online shows several
members of The Shadow cabinet haven't
even shared these new attack ads on
their own Twitter feed
but will focusing on Rishi sunak in this
way even work one conservative pier and
pollster thinks not if they've been
going at Boris then people wouldn't have
reacted in the way that they have done
but there is a sense looking at it that
it's concern the message isn't getting
across and they're probably attacking
the wrong person in that Rishi is
perceived not to be in the same
rumbustious style as Boris was
the Tories today accuse secure starmer
of being a lefty lawyer on the side of
terrorists and pedophiles the long arm
of the law are high priority as many
wonder whether this political debate is
reaching a new low
robowski news in Westminster